les véhicules de la police
nord-irlandaise se déploie dimanche soir
pour disperser les manifestants de la
mouvance unionistes le camp politique
qui soutient le maintien de la province
au sein du royaume uni selon les forces
de l'ordre une vingtaine de personnes
ont mené une attaque orchestrée
je tends notamment des cocktails molotov
contre les policiers
le gouvernement britannique a condamné
ces violences
il n'y a aucune excuse pour la violence
pas maintenant jamais ceux qui se
livrent à la violence et à la
criminalité n'ont rien à offrir leurs
actions ne sont pas voulu et ne sauront
jamais toléré je remercie tous ces
policiers qui continue de travailler dur
pour protéger les gens du danger
ces incidents sont directement liés à la
mise en oeuvre de l'accord sur le brésil
et à ses conséquences pour l'irlande du
nord
les unionistes rejette le protocole
négocié entre londres et l'union
européenne un accord qui introduit des
contrôles sur les marchandises arrivant
en irlande du nord depuis la
grande-bretagne double objectif pour
bruxelles éviter le retour d'une
frontières douanières avec la république
d'irlande et préserver le marché unique
européen
selon lui eu le retour d'une barrière
douanière entre les deux irlande
risquerait de fragiliser la paix conclu
en 1998 entre les principales forces
politiques d'irlande du nord
une paix qui mettait fin à 30 ans de
guerre entre unionistes et républicains
irlandais dans ce contexte londres a
unilatéralement repoussé au 1er octobre
prochain la mise en place de ce
protocole afin de laisser du temps aux
entreprises
nous prenons des mesures légales et
techniques pour construire la confiance
c'est la bonne chose à faire vu l'impact
sur l'accord de paix du vendredi saint
et le besoin d'avoir le consentement des
deux communautés
mais l'initiative britannique n'est pas
du goût de la commission européenne qui
accuse londres d'avoir violé les règles
douanières convenu pour l'irlande du
nord
bruxelles a annoncé l'ouverture de deux
procédures contre le royaume uni